[Música]
esto que rara vez termino lavando
El holocausto nota una enorme carga que creo.
quién sabe si Trivia Alissa lo está hablando
No, miro la narrativa del Caballero.
La vida humana settevisa Jesolo que uno
tener la manifestación de la guerra
illomisano cuando es famoso
es imposible calificarlo de que es
el holocausto significa que las Caravanas
cuando eh este show
estamos apostando y el error pero grande
que como timos un clima cumple con el
humanidad siempre y cuando haya proporcionado uno cuando sea
último
aspolítico importa quiénes son
desconcertos uno se esta perdiendo es el
valor humano pero importante pregunté
pregunté mientras conducía
el guía humano
amigos
significa que ya estás en la cabeza que ya tienes
más allá del punto de exclamación